if anyone's ever eaten horses you I
haven't tried it no way
he's probably [__] shot a horse with
a bow and arrow and dragged it back by
himself barefoot
[Music]
welcome back to the best episode ever of
the careful boys where the boys are
officially back in town for the first
time
over two months because Steve's been
missing the entire time wait wait I
don't think that's true he's been
missing Indonesia selling cars Anthony's
been dancing in [__] Sri Lanka
[__] trying to sell tripods and [__]
Nepal dude dude how was Bengali right
where were you really yeah where'd you
go you went to Vietnam right didn't we
already talked about all this before no
you gotta say it here for Steve Steve
didn't hear it well now it's the real
six so you're this is officially you
being back this is the careful boy there
was a fake six let's get the real story
where were you because you were back as
a substitute teacher last time okay so I
I had a wholesale deal on used cars
[Music]
came back from China uh working on the
tour went to India to go teach I
actually just came from back from
Kazakhstan whoa no way how was
Kazakhstan hey is it little say it don't
say it don't say it
that's the hot bitch's face that's a hot
bitch's face I saw a cop they're all
about Ryan's looking over there that's
what I'm saying it's like a land of
papas it's like you got a full-on blonde
Russian and a Chinese girl and then in
the middle of your life you look like
you belong in Hawaii but you have no tan
I don't even know Kazakhstan was real
trying to be respectful but I was like
how did you guys feel about Borax she's
like I hated it we all hate it I don't
even think they filmed it in Kazakhstan
it's not a representation it was like a
gypsy Village in Romania yeah yeah there
was a country that like in 24 Jack
Bowers going after but it wasn't real
and I thought that was kind of a stand
but I think it's something else is that
similar to the country that uh Tom Hanks
came from in the terminal oh oh which
one is that one uh it's like a whole
country that's like a MIG you know like
the migs but you just make a nation yeah
yeah but that talk about Kazakhstan
you're just there I've always wanted to
go there it was my first one dude it
took like 24 hours for me to get there
oh [__] why because all the layovers
yeah it's just there's only one day over
it's just you have to go like 16 hours
to guitar then you you lay over there
then you do like five hours over to
Kazakhstan yeah five hours plain or like
bus or like oh here's the [__]
sickest part though other than the
everybody's hop which is the first
country I've been to in like forever
where every I'm not say every but on
average every chick was above average in
my opinion of course they're [__]
mixing for centuries yeah that's a good
way to put it Russian girls are hot
Northern Chinese girls are hot you put
them together they go hotter dude I was
in Sweden some hot ass in Sweden I'll
tell you that it's cold
so here's the thing so uh that's what
this video turns into one of the
craziest things that happened is uh
we're driving [__] just down one of
the streets because we're just like
sightseeing the first day that we get
there and then um on a bus stop like
poster it's like Black Eyed Peas concert
right and I'm like no [__] way one of
my homies is Black Ops uh he's taboo
he's a [__] uh Native American Latino
like Hispanic everything like that right
the super mixed guy and then uh we did a
music video firm back in like 2016 or
some [__] like that so uh we Google uh
when the concert is and it's that
Saturday so we Happen To Be An Almighty
Kazakhstan at the same time so no
[__] way so I text this guy yeah I'm
like yo are you in custom he's like yo I
just landed what's popping tonight it's
like what's going on over there no oh
that's cool so it's just coincidence
just coincidence like what are the
chances that word causes at the same
time you were hanging out with Fergie
left she's not in it anymore she's not
she's not
so bad
that's their Cuisine because they're
like Mongolians dude at McDonald's so
apparently horse Donalds no you know
what's crazy we asked about McDonald's
but apparently it's uh you can't it's
not called McDonald's out there anymore
because of like Russia and stuff oh wow
what's it called because of the war so
it's called like food Republic or some
[__] like or Food Food Solutions I don't
know Food Solutions crazy really weird
[__] that's so communist oh I'm hungry I
have a food solution for you yeah not a
good Brandy though it's kind of good
branding three layer sandwich
[Laughter]
damn that's [__] crazy yeah so so
went party with them
um and [__] went to their concert the
next day how was the concert it was
[__] you know what's crazy it's
hilarious yeah you said yeah because of
how many bangers they actually have oh
like think about it like so many of
their songs you like but who's singing
for Fergie though it's actually
um this uh half black half Filipina girl
who won I don't know if it was The Voice
or whatever on Apple the apps game yeah
so they they brought her in she's dope
too she kind of seems like Fergie but
she's dope dude Filipinos they just take
over all like the iconic they're really
good yeah 100 like Ryan and JK news
they're like our like like that
and whatever band he was playing with
before that could probably replace all
of Journey
do you watch that documentary they were
kind of dicks to him too it was really
they did a good job on the doc they
treated a lot they treated him like [__]
they were kind of no he was like trying
to he was like trying he was like he
just joined the group and he's [__]
like getting on top of the speakers and
[__] like hey dude you gotta take it you
got to relax you gotta take it that's a
little much though he's just rocking out
yeah he's just letting his butter wings
and he's been covering for so long oh
yeah yeah I think it was that I think he
used butterfly wings fly too much and
they're like yo flap less like chill
dude but he's so used to he's been
performing Journey songs forever too I
know exactly not on top of speakers dude
you can't be climate speaker that's true
not in Muslim countries dude that's like
a minimum five-year thing you know what
I mean also Journey fans are kind of
like in their 60s now so like get on
speakers makes them all nervous oh
that's really dangerous how how that's
really dangerous
Urban Hal yeah yeah was it a big culture
shock in Kazakhstan does it feel like a
complete no not so much because I felt
like I was looking at a bunch of Asians
but doesn't it trip you out though
because they're actually like more
Russian everyone's speaking Russian
right they speak Russian they speak
English they speak kazak were you like
hey let's go Ukraine huh
well I mean they had their own
independence so you know what I mean so
it's like they've been pushing for their
own independence I think since like 1991
I was like learning about their [__]
their the youth right now are making a
big like push to push like the Kazakh
language to be kind of like the national
language even though most people
especially the Boomers and stuff speak
Russian oh because it was taken over by
Soviet Soviet Russia right yeah so I
heard that they're hella [__]
um uh controlled by organized crime yeah
how do you feel about that yeah I'm
hearing about it I'm feeling about it
for the first time Joe Joe heard it from
one guy and now that's just how it is
and that guy was a feudal Japanese guy
how's the language sound
yeah do your best Impressions yeah can
you put do you do like 10 minutes can
you flip that switch real quick all I
know is I think we said the word douche
or something like Elijah Dushku yeah
something like that just be like that's
dope
not hot pizza
[Laughter]
I mean just thank you because people are
saying like spicy ball as like thank you
in Russian but a good afternoon it means
like thank you this is spicy Bowl sick
like spicy boy spicy boy spicy boy spicy
spicy something like that spicy boys
like the kazak version of us
something like that dude spicy boy is
way better than careful boys yeah let me
just change it way better
that should be our food channel
spicy boys they eat hella horse horses
bomb horse is Bomb do you have a
hankering for horse do you have a
craving for horses
so fun I want to try you go to Stables
you're just like if anyone's ever eaten
horses you I haven't tried it no way
this is delicious Barton he's probably
[__] shot
because all the animal uh activists were
like we gotta let them go and I'm like
yeah we gotta let them go to my stomach
and then yeah then we harvested you put
on a pivot knife it just fell on the
table Bart how is it you like it yeah I
had a like a Benihana's in Japan or
something no way it's like
but I think I think Barton day
to a store and then you guys didn't even
know it was a horse store no it was just
we walked it so we're just like we're
hungry we're going down the street of
like all the shops this is horse
branding and then we're like dude we're
[__] hungry oh let's get some
barbecue the Korean barbecue Japanese
barbecue whatever and then we just smell
all this meat smoke coming from this one
spot I'm like oh hell yeah we walk in
there we sit down and then I start
looking around and there's a big like
kanji like which is Japanese lettering a
horse on the wall I was sick maybe
that's their last name remember Barbie's
Japanese
there's like calligraphy paintings of
horses all over the place I'm like damn
orange really [__] love horses that's
pretty cool
yeah it came out and then I was like
dance doesn't really smell like beef
what does it smell like what would you
best guess it smelled like somewhere in
between like a sir like I guess like elk
it just smells like off beef
but I was like they don't have view it
not a good horse I'm like they don't got
USDA here they probably got their own
[__] you know not even the vegans call
their [__] off beef that's off beef
sounds like rotted meat that sounds like
high fashion but we found out those
horses were like [__] it we're in
another country anyways we ate it and it
was juicy and had like a slight
sweetness to it this is really good yeah
you know like the Mongol like horde
that's all they ate because I was like
wondering
how did they when they went out and then
like if they weren't like pillaging
Villages what did they eat and basically
they [__] they just killed the horses
like in their crew but it's not eating
like eating your car yeah basically they
would eat their [__] well one's edible
I think the people strand of the desert
would love to be able to eat their car
that's true they eat their [__] they
drink the horse milk that dude um but
you run out of milk if you eat the horse
that's true which one you eat first you
know because you have to dip the horse
meat in the milk right it goes down
easier I'm sure they lost a couple
horses though you know Bizarre Foods
yeah the Andrew uh whatever Zimmer they
did a whole episode of like traditional
foods right and everything was just
hoarse like even the fire they made was
like from horse [__] so the horse [__]
they didn't even have wood and stuff
they used a horse dried horse [__] they
[__] get a whole horse they would eat
the horse and then they would have like
milk from it and all that stuff and then
they would have this horse cheese horse
milk horse beer of course yeah did you
see all kinds of horse products like
that like everything yeah so I guess
like apparently with Kazakhstan like
Kazakh means some some sort it's
basically a Wandering country like
Nomads so the whole culture comes from
like people needing to be able to like
cure their foods and sour milk and stuff
in order to be able to travel with it
for like months so like all their milk
stuff is like yeah hell of soured which
I didn't like any of that stuff to be
completely honest did you try that milk
beer that they had not that beer but I
definitely had some like lamb or cheese
milk type [__] that was like so a lot of
[__] is sour there yeah and so they even
have like among a lot of the horse
dishes also is like like cured horse
meat like horse sausage that's cured so
it's like almost like a salami but horse
which is really good but it's also it
feels a lot more like Rich so you don't
want to eat too much of it but like just
the the cooked [__] horse meat is
super bomb you know like literally
Korean barbecue stuff but just like
horse meat just it's all fatty and just
a giant piece of [__] meat what's
their like hamburger like what's their
like staple horse Burger that's not
that's not like ground horse some cured
sour [__] like do they got like this is
a our this is our burger and fries all I
know is they don't eat pork there
because they're Muslim I didn't dive
into the religious background you
respected the Privacy yeah
I didn't see any that's why I was like
is this a scam what's going on bro you
didn't ask to get some food Solutions I
tried to but then at the same time like
we barely had time so we were just like
eating we're like get us some Cosmic
food and then get us to our our
workshops did you did you eat the horse
head
no it's not a Scarface what is this dude
oh maybe that's Mongolian but yeah in
the plane no there that's a thing that
they do it's like they get they steam a
whole [__] horse head a whole head
like as a casual meal and then they just
[__] pick at it yeah that's at their
food Solutions I guess that makes sense
like Cabeza tacos right it's like same
thing you're eating ahead of uh yeah no
waste that makes sense yeah I guess so
it's the thing that gets ordered the
most have that just like Cabeza tacos
steamed horse headphones
that's pretty wild yeah but that was fun
came back and you know getting ready for
hitting the clouds so that's that's all
I've been and then I [__] missed you
last time I was here missed you missed
you I saw a bunch of videos about you
guys [__] I don't know what you're
talking about did you notice that most
episodes just become about you and
you're not here yeah we talk about you a
lot well don't make me bring up the
grinder episodes about you
and how everybody that's a picture hey
dude you're next bro there's there's
like three more in pre-production so
don't worry about it there's more coming
dude if we do a grinder profile for you
Brian has to get a new phone oh yeah I
gotta get a new life he's gotta get a
new life dude you guys go off the grid
we should have kept tally to see like
once it's who's whoever's whose turn how
much dick they're gonna be Nick was a
[__] dick magnet how do you make the
dick magnet how do you beat that right
deleted the app and it still was having
push notifications it was crazy if
there's a will there's a way dude wow so
so you extrapolate what I got imagine
what Anthony Allegiance dude but look at
you like you are a dramatic right now
like you got like brandless shirt you
got a pink [__] Fitbit on with the
Yellow Hat you buff as [__] like I will
say though dude everything about you is
so hot due to the time of day I think we
were getting a lot of depressed gays oh
two to the time
because it's during the day if you're on
a dating app at like 11 o'clock in the
morning
but what if we get the early riser gays
that are like they're they're kind of
like more like Bart they wake up early
they start their day early and then
they're just they're hunting for some
dong before like the end of day I saw
them they weren't that no
what time was it like around 11 it was
before lunch but 10 30 11. nah they're
unproductive they're jobless we gotta do
like 8 A.M I think I think that's the
yeah like 8 A.M like 5 a.m you get the
Buffalo [__] this guy texted us we
texted last night about how we're
excited we were to finally see each
other this guy texted us at 6 15 in the
morning yeah sometimes is that what time
that was yeah
sometimes I wish I was gay what do you
mean okay because uh but then the thing
is I don't like dick but the thing is
for one problem gay young gay couples
have the most sex the most they bust it
down a lot I'm sure yeah glowy City I
bet Glory City yeah and blowing for
anything it's just in general because
like dudes are obviously always in
desire of sexy way more than women and
then you put dude and dude and it's like
whole and then you don't have to wait
for your birthday to get a [__] we'll
tell you that and they are the highest
earning couples oh are they yeah wow and
they're the buffest probably certain
parts like maybe I mean yeah something
for everyone
so they they [__] the most they make the
most
they you know do they have a higher rate
of staying together probably not oh I
just made that up but I assume that
they're just cheating all day I would
imagine they would because they can't
you know you're like I like this I like
the straight guy Roundtable on how good
it is to be gay
look there's perks to everything you
know we just gotta look we should look
for the silver lights just jealousy all
around it's like we're in Kazakhstan and
we didn't get the [__] food plus
give me your local thing and I gotta get
on the [__] plane
[__] food surplus yeah dude Food
Solutions that is a really good name did
you miss that part of the conversation
he hates me there's no logo yeah we
didn't we didn't see any everyone I just
imagine all communist like countries
having zero Brands back in the day like
Soviet style it's just [__] store
Supply you know kind of makes it easier
it's like the old west yeah I know
because you're like you're driving by
you're like what the [__] is in a church
that's kind of like Hawaiian like food
Land
oh yeah it's just straight up it's just
like this is what it is that'd be like
seeing signs say Bank Sheriff yeah like
more jail yeah you know Hannah said
that's a school plan that's basically
just America she was she said that when
she came here she was surprised at all
the big signs at stores just basically
it is what it is like locksmith or like
Market or like you would see that you
don't really see that out there and I
was like it's like everything's branded
or locksmith like yeah well you don't
see the name of the store and I was like
oh you're [__] right like when you go
there you don't see like big [__]
banners of like names on top it's just
they just look like buildings and then
you look inside the store and then it's
also they don't have signs over there
not like us ours is just literal yeah so
I'm like oh [__] that's why we're better
dude you know where it's not literal if
you go to [__] Star Wars land
everything's written in Star Wars
language and I'm like I don't even know
where I am where's the locksmith
language I'm like what the [__] going
on here you're in Kazakhstan somewhere
some nerds can tell you what's what yeah
exactly that's scary they could read it
that's scary you know speak it sounds
like you're not a real fan dude dude I
don't speak it I guess I'm not it's
you're like he calls it stair Wars
I do it now too because of you I think
you should they're worse it's good
Ryan
are we going to talk about it wait what
are we going to talk about so serious
where were you when we hit 2 million oh
this this is the moment in the video we
should wait till the next video yeah
we'll wait we're just happy to have
Anthony back right guys
it's happy to have all this keeps coming
back he hasn't taken a day off yeah
Steve's here every month he's been here
a lot dude if you if you actually count
the amount of days I've still been here
more than Steve this wait what
really is that true yeah oh cause you
guys are here twice yeah yeah yeah but
that's not fair dude you live here
that's you live in Glendale
but you travel the most miles out of all
of us here so you're the problem what do
you use your miles for yeah you know
what's crazy I don't have an efficient
method of that because like I'm not
always flying the same uh Airline
partner oh okay you know versus
consolidating all your points to one
place I have them spread over a bunch of
different places even include why don't
you get there's two Star Alliance I
already got it and one world best it's
one world now one world is American uh
Airlines and then okay Star Alliance is
United and then Delta is the other one
what kind of what kind of lounges you
got access to bro I bet you got some
crazy you know what's crazy I used to
have like gold and first land access
lounge access for like United which is
dope yeah but the problem is they keep
on like inflation they keep on upping
the requirements and how much you have
to spend and how many miles you have to
rack and then once the pandemic hit I
lost basically all status everywhere so
you can you still have your miles for a
bunch of stuff but like you have to to
rebuild your status and spending dollars
per quarter what if you use your AMEX
card that gets into a bunch of lounges
one thing is I also don't book My
Flights organizers book My Flights uh
you know what I mean
yeah they're getting all the they're
scooping up no you know what you do is
you put your frequent flyer number on
the ticket no I still do but that's what
I'm saying I'm getting points for the
airline partners that they happen to
book wow so it's not like I can choose
like I want everything to be under this
Airline partner but when I do have
points that I save up over years and
stuff like that I end up just using them
on like vacation stuff for me and Nina
which I'm going to do we're going on a
new Honeymoon by the way oh nice what's
a mini one yeah my name is because I
also have to do some work in between but
that's because I wanted to help
subsidize payment for stuff so tomorrow
we're actually going to go to Bali for
the first time yeah Molly is awesome
if you all got recommendations oh yes oh
yeah you want to go on our honeymoon
yeah yeah so that's a huge one we'll go
together not see each other but be there
at the same time and then have different
places yeah and then you gotta carve on
a tree like a heart and then I'll come
by and I'll put my name on it
that's cool man so doing that and then
heading over to Taiwan for work real
quick and some golf uh and then heading
over to Tokyo because she hasn't been
there to Tokyo before but also you're
doing like three stops yeah wow so it's
gonna be like just under two weeks but
taiwan's my work one that doesn't sound
mini to me yeah for real well it's
because I have to work in between that's
a legit honeymoon most people go one
place you're going to three and you're
calling a mini that's [__] up yeah
[__] you Anthony right called privilege
there's a lot of people saying that that
being said though the cool thing about
it is that because I'm working in Taiwan
uh that's what covers my international
flight personally that's tight you know
what I'm saying so I just have to even
before Bali have to fly through Taiwan
and then do connecting flights and then
I'm just using my Taiwan salary to pay
for the rest of the trip
not like break even yeah outside of
expense like for honeymoon stuff that's
pretty oh hey in Kazakhstan how's the
dance level are they really good or are
they dated no some places are dated
um some are pretty damn I'm good and the
cool thing about it is that at this
particular camp that I went to like five
different countries showed up like
Kyrgyzstan like Russian people came like
you know different people came from
different places all the stands yeah so
like there were really really dope
dancers there but as far as Kazakhstan
like as an individual level I think that
they're okay they're okay but they also
probably don't have a lot of
international teachers coming there it's
like super difficult to travel there you
know what I mean it like takes so long
that's cool you went up plus all they
got to eat is [__] sour [__] so a lot
of people like I don't want to go there
just Warheads
warheads and horse
can't even get a bowl of oatmeal that
stuff messes up inside [__] preserve
beats and you know a lot of dancers are
vegan so what are they gonna do is there
a ton of 911 deniers in Kirk can't stand
you were able to find a lot of cultural
identities yeah